[Música]
en France 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión iniciamos
con la misión Dart de la NASA también
llamada prueba de direccionamiento de
asteroide doble se trata de una misión
que busca que por primera vez una nave
espacial choque directamente contra un
asteroide para que ese cuerpo cambie de
rumbo si todo sale según lo planeado la
prueba se realizará el próximo 26 de
septiembre la nave viaja hacia un
sistema de dos asteroides llamado
didimos que en griego significa gemelos
y está compuesto por un gran asteroide
homónimo y otro más pequeño que lo
orbita llamado dimorfos justamente ese
cuerpo más pequeño del tamaño de un
estadio de fútbol es el que buscará
impactar y que cambie de rumbo
esta prueba es solo una parte
constantemente buscamos en los cielos
nuevos asteroides y amenazas potenciales
y en general el tamaño de dimorfos está
en una clase que ya sabes es de lo que
más preocupa alrededor de 140 160 metros
Entonces esta prueba ayudará nos dará
confianza de que tenemos una estrategia
de mitigación En caso de que alguna vez
se identifique una amenaza
los expertos explican que la misión
podría convertirse en una verdadera
hazaña si llega a ser exitosa dada la
alta posibilidad de fracaso el plan es
que la nave impacte este asteroide a
24.000 kilómetros por hora golpeándolo
lo suficientemente fuerte como para
cambiar su trayectoria orbital alrededor
del asteroide más grande las cámaras
montadas en el impactador y en una mini
nave espacial del tamaño de un maletín
que se lanzará desde Dark unos 10 días
registrarán la colisión y transmitirán
imágenes de regreso a la tierra
por la forma en que hemos estado
transmitiendo lo bien que nos ha ido
hasta ahora creemos que podríamos
obtener imágenes hasta dos segundos y
medio antes del impacto O tal vez
Incluso un segundo y medio antes
entonces realmente lo estás viendo en
tiempo real estás viendo ese impacto el
sistema dividimos está ubicado a 11
millones de kilómetros de la tierra Por
lo que no representa ningún riesgo para
el planeta no obstante si podría ser El
Punto de partida para mejorar la
tecnología de redireccionamiento de
cuerpos que en un futuro puedan
representar algún riesgo para la tierra
cambiamos de tema y vamos a Israel
porque cada vez son más las
posibilidades que ofrece la tecnología
de impresión 3D y científicos de la
universidad hebrea de Jerusalén
desarrollaron Una pasta a base de madera
que después de pasar por una impresora
3D se seca y toma la forma del diseño
que se estableció de antemano
entonces lo que estamos haciendo es
colocar una tinta una tinta de madera
dentro de una extrusora y luego
depositamos el material sobre un
sustrato estamos fabricando un objeto 2D
o un objeto 2D con espesor y luego
dejamos que el agua se evapore Y
entonces la madera se encoge y se
deformas
si imprimimos con caudales altos
velocidades altas o caudales lentos o si
estamos haciendo diferentes patrones de
impresión el resultado final será
diferente tenemos este buen control
tanto del lado teórico del modelo de lo
que sucederá como de lado práctico de
una tinta que puede cambiar y deformarse
a través del tiempo y luego puede
hacerse diferentes coberturas en los
diferentes objetos
lo que los expertos buscan es crear un
material que cambie con el tiempo que se
deforme como lo hace la madera natural
por ello una vez que los fluidos de la
tinta que están hechos de desechos de
madera y de otros ingredientes naturales
se secan cambia de forma esto se
controla con la cantidad de capas y la
velocidad de impresión el producto final
está diseñado para hacer reciclable
sostenible e imitar a la naturaleza
creo que lo más importante El material
es que es realmente sostenible por lo
tanto no tenemos ninguna resina a base
de formaldehído no hay materiales
sintéticos todo esa base de madera así
por ejemplo si hay una silla rota
podemos tomarla cortarla y luego puede
imprimir su propia silla una y otra vez
no queremos que las cosas duren para
siempre sino que dure 3 4 o 5 años y
luego puedes volver a imprimirlo no
queremos que los materiales duren para
siempre en la naturaleza
y nos desplazamos hasta Australia según
la oficina australiana de estadísticas
cada año se reciclan cerca de 40
millones de toneladas de residuo lo que
representa alrededor de la mitad de los
desechos que se producen en el país un
equipo del centro global de tecnologías
de Big Data de la universidad
tecnológica de Sydney una papelera o
basurero inteligente que es capaz de
clasificar los desechos y que incluso
identifica el tipo de plástico para
poder aprovechar mejor los materiales
reciclables que se pueden transformar en
nuevos materiales
esta máquina puede clasificar diferentes
tipos de desechos incluidos vasos latas
de metal y plásticos y lo sorprendentes
que puede reconocer diferentes tipos de
plásticos incluidos Pet y después de
catalogarlos puede clasificar los
diferentes desechos en diferentes
contenedores
combinamos las últimas tecnologías
incluido internet de las cosas usamos
diferentes sensores para detectar el
peso la materia los materiales
los responsables del proyecto aseguran
que gracias a la Inteligencia artificial
el sistema está en constante aprendizaje
para lograr clasificar productos nuevos
de acuerdo con su material y apariencia
así no los haya visto antes
así llegamos al final de este espacio a
Muchas gracias por su sintonía continúen
con nosotros en France 24 y France
24.com
[Música]